welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
glass here with tommy bechtol and we are
at star wars celebration 2022. we just
got out of the lucasfilm studio showcase
sorry about my uh the camera is
jiggling a bit because i'm super excited
about what we saw oh my god that was
incredible we saw uh the panel for andor
and that's gonna be the trailer that we
are reacting to in this video we're
doing a live reaction live reaction we
tommy and i are surrounded by cosplayers
cosplayers uh excited fans people who
are harrison ford's wandering around
here
uh john williams we got to see him we
learned about uh the new skeleton crew
series a bit about ahsoka mandalorian
season three coming february 2023 but
right now let's react you're gonna see
our live reactions to the andor trailer
we did see it in there but we were just
kind of like late at wash over there we
had not great view from where we're
sitting so you're going to see us react
to like good quality footage for the
first time right here right now
let's do it
i like this guy i love this guy he's the
rancor trainer of this generation
just the ringing of the bell here
it's such a cool recurring thing
throughout his trailer like each clang
gives us our edit
and the intensity is raw it's
awesome
and look how much like nature imagery
we're getting right it feels like a real
cross of like
primitive cultures with the modern
empire technology for sure like some of
this was shot in the volume but a lot of
this looks like it was shot on location
which is like a nice change of pace
from what we've been seeing from star
wars lately
so that were those three ships is that
one of the ships that he flies in rogue
one does he have like a stolen one of
those well when we first see him it's on
the rebel base and we know that guys
sorry to interrupt myself but
everyone's so bitter and they're
everywhere
oh yeah we got her casting
today
yeah o'reilly looks great and how like
scared she looks like it looks like a
political thriller for her yeah it's a
king's bomb yeah
those bases look awesome
there will be no rules going forward
this is by the way this is more than a
theater it's a full team this is a full
trail this is the four pieces
let's go
wow
august 31st first two episodes
all right tommy tell me your thoughts
from that andor trailer what do you
think well i'm so excited you know i
have to be honest at first i was like i
don't know that a whole and or show is
gonna like hold our interest in i can't
they said they got 12 episodes coming
with another toss to that and i said do
another 12 after that yeah right
give me a hundred episodes
yeah just really stretch out as much as
you can these five years or four years
well diego luna is so likable too yeah
you're like watching him be a scumbag in
the beginning like right he's gonna be
it's like oh man everything we've heard
about this show is great tony gilroy the
executive producer said that they've
shot 12 episodes so far they have 12
more that they're going to start
shooting in november he said the final
shot the final scene of the series is uh
going to tie us directly into where we
start with cassie and endor and rogue
one i assume the rings of capri that
mission that he was on we're going to
find out some context about uh the guy
he was chasing down and the guy he
killed to get that critical information
for the death star um one of the cool
things that we've learned about sorry
i'm switching hands
one of the coolest things we've learned
about this is that you're going to see a
society get corrupted through propaganda
get militarized and radicalized by the
imperial propaganda on the show and uh
just the whole political game is i think
what i'm most excited about all my
series is that transition and we get
some stellan scars guard stone
rebel commander it sounds like on the
series looks like it was on location
shot rather than just tons of blue
screens and all those led monitors i i
can't wait i'm sorry yeah great so now
let's talk about like the the pacing and
the structure of this show it sounds
like we're gonna get 12 episodes of a
season this is going to be the longest
season of anything on disney plus right
because one division was nine episodes
uh what if was was not more than ten
episodes so let's talk about that what
uh what does that tell us about this
series the fact that it's going to be 12
episodes uh 11 weeks of content that
we're going to be living with in the
fall to me it just tells me that they're
building a whole different world inside
this galaxy there's a lot of new people
introduce us to yeah that might
potentially have their own offshoots you
know this show may spin off into movies
and
and and other tv shows in ways we don't
realize because everything can be
connected in this galaxy we're getting
to meet all these new characters at a
really tumultuous time so when is it
ever not tumultuous i know
yeah i think um it was interesting tony
gilroy was asked about possible cameos
on this series and he was very
tight-lipped he said you know maybe next
time when we meet it's like next time
next time we're going to be talking
we're already going to know like howard
the duck what was he doing
i mean this period of star wars history
this is the years before uh a new hope
but the years before rogue one this is
the years during rebels so i feel like a
lot of the star wars rebels characters
could show up we could see harris
syndulla like if we if we don't see some
of the crew members of the ghost we're
gonna be missing out a lot uh this is a
great chance for us to see maul yeah and
everything that he was doing when he
intersected with ezra bridger
potentially see some more inquisitors
follow up with some of these characters
hopefully if they're able to survive in
in uh obi-wan kenobi uh like i would be
a bit bummed if moses ingram's character
riva the the third sister gets killed
off this could be a chance to continue
her story absolutely uh and and see what
other [ __ ] she gets into other people
she hunts down uh like if we don't see
these story lines from rebels of like
how the grand inquisitor was able to
capture luminar unduly this could be
something that gets explored here in
this series there's so many 12 episodes
we have so much now it feels like i'm
sure when it comes out we're going to be
like oh there's not enough episodes
right we don't have to fit it all in
right in specific episodes we can we can
have some breathing room some time to
explore that's one thing that i thought
was really great about mandalorian
season one is there was no like kind of
pressing timeline we're just going to
like live in its vibes with like grogu
in in mando and now we can have a bit
more time to breathe some vibes with uh
with cassian and or some vibes some some
breathing room getting a k2so cameo
right oh yes let's get k2so i mean
pretty much anyone from the rebel
leadership uh that we saw in those
opening scenes yes uh could cross over
into this show right like maybe finally
some chances to explore jedha a bit more
unfortunately saw that plateau get
destroyed in rogue one
i mean could force whitaker show up on
this yes what will you become ursula
like these guys like all this world gets
to be revisited and i think now over the
years that rogue one has gained an
appreciation that's like people have
come around on and realized how how
great that movie is and how fun this
chapter of the star wars history really
is so i'm just excited to be living in
it and
tony gilroy seems to be like he's a kid
in a toy store right how was the big
theme of this whole panel was everybody
felt so excited about the projects
they're working out and i mean i just
you can't help but get hyped for it yeah
wait
well uh there's a lot more coming out uh
from star wars celebration so tomorrow
will be my in-depth uh frame by frame
breakdown of the android trail i'm gonna
run back to the hotel room to work on
that right i'm gonna buy toys
tommy's gonna actually be living the
star wars celebration experience but
i'll be living vicariously through him
tonight we're gonna get a chance to
watch the first two episodes of obi-wan
kenobi and uh we'll have our uh
wikileaks episode reacting to that and
discussing the big questions we may try
to find a fun location around here to
shoot that in we'll see we'll figure it
out uh and then my breakdowns for
obi-wan episode one will that will come
out saturday my breakdown of episode two
will come out sunday we just need some
time to really write those and focus on
them luckily i'll have a chance to see
those episodes a bit early so i might
have a head start but uh got a lot of
work ahead of us yes we're loving it
here in anaheim and uh
if if you see us if you're here come say
hi we we love meeting all of you
absolutely yeah all right and i'll hold
the camera and take eric's picture i
don't mind you won't hurt my feelings if
you don't know who i am we have a new
latest obsession uh obi-wan inspired
shirt that you can get at new
yorkstarsmerch.com it's the best way to
support us here at new rockstars uh
follow me at ea boss follow tommy at
tommy beck told subscribe to your
rockstars following rockstars on all
social media thanks for watching bye
everybody
[Music]
you